foreign
[Music]
welcome we're going to start this
morning is everyone ready
are people old enough to remember 2006
developers developers developers
developers developers developers oh okay
I guess everyone's a little too
Millennial no
anyways hello welcome uh today we're
doing imagination of the creation
building a differentiated generative AI
application with Google Cloud
we have our team
hi everyone my name is JC I work at ipso
say Global Market Research company and
I'm the global head of grvi
okay hello everyone my name is Holt
Skinner I'm a developer advocate for
Google Cloud focused in artificial
intelligence and machine learning and
I'm based in Austin Texas and my name is
Josh I am one of the product managers
working in vertex Ai and we're here to
talk about
we're going to go through today a
developer Journey showing you some
overview of what we're doing lately with
vertex AI more specifically we're
actually going to solve a real user
problem or customer problem and we're
going to go through a developer journey
and show multiple ways in which we're
solving this from a more built or out of
the box all the way down to
componentized and heavy development
application orientation and then we'll
go through a little bit of details about
what that looks like under the hood in
our Solutions and the nice thing about
today is everything's going to be a live
demo
I hope it does
so in short if you're not familiar this
over here is a nice little overview of
what we're doing in vertex the reason
why we're showing this is because at the
top here we have some AI Solutions get
people familiar with things like contact
center AI or document Ai and other
Suites that we have that are a little
more pre-built still allows you to
customize tune so on and so forth we
also have under here we recently
announced GA for search and conversation
as capabilities and also more pre-built
flows and then we have our core AI
platform and under this we have model
Garden which is all of our models that
we're offering so this is a kind of
brief overview and sort of an
understanding of how you can keep going
deeper and deeper into the stack to
build your solution
and with that we're going to be able to
talk about our customer
problems
um so thank you everyone for the
opportunity to share a little bit of
details of our generative AI Journey
with Google cloud and more specifically
a high liver high-level description of a
business problem we're trying to solve
um just to set the stage I work at a
market research Global Market Research
company we have over 19 000 employees
across 84 plus countries and there is a
strong momentum around General AI within
my company with teams
testing new ideas building prototypes
and finding new ways to create and
capture value across the four categories
of use cases that you see on the screen
whether it's discovering new insights or
sympathizing summarizing large purpose
of data or creating content to enhance
the delivery of insights or automation
we have literally hundreds of use cases
we want to go through and it feels like
the list increases every week
um
if now let's bring the conversation down
one level and let's focus on let's talk
about the use cases we're prioritizing
in the short term
we are testing vertex AI search in two
of those use cases one of them is the
multi-source insights and the other use
cases is about a virtual assistant for
employees
to find questions to their most common
questions and find the right documents
as they join the company
one of these virtual assistants is
called ask ipsos our objective which as
keeps us is to improve the experience
the onboarding experience of new
employees
to
help them navigate what might feel like
a complex organization
first by providing a low friction always
on chatbot assistant who is an expert in
our institutional knowledge
now the biggest challenge that we have
to deliver on that uh business problem
is that our institutional knowledge is
hyper fragmented across many data silos
whether it's internal Wiki sites or
internal chats or collaboration sites or
just share documents being passed around
over email or we have a lot of
institutional knowledge spread across
the company and it's very difficult to
find the right answer to us sometimes
simple questions
so we want to make us keeps us the go-to
place for new employees to find answers
to their most common questions and find
the right documents uh without having to
interact with another colleague
the the reason I I believe uh vertex AI
search is a good match for this use case
is because it allows us to focus on the
employee experience by abstracting away
the the complexities of ingesting data
indexing documents managing the vector
store and whatnot all while providing
the Privacy security and governance that
we've come to expect from Google Cloud
now our definition of success well it
begins with
uh we want to leave behind the old days
where
a new employee will have to send an
email or a chat message to a colleague
to find an answer to a question and then
wait what sometimes feels like a very
long time
we want them to be able to interact with
us apesos for that
secondly we want to provide high quality
search results to our colleagues ideally
in the first results page and allow them
to find the right documents that they
need within the first group of results
and finally thinking more strategically
I believe that having an easier access
to our institutional knowledge will
prevent in the long term Global
distributed teams from Reinventing the
will and doing duplicative work if they
have the if they find the right answer
if they find the right documents then
most likely we will not be reventing the
will the will over and over again
now with that said I do want to pass it
back to Josh
so here we're going to go through the
developer Journey on a couple of these
experiences that we're able to make do
you want to get ready for the demos yeah
and Holt is going to help us by actually
showing us some really awesome demos
that we built along the way
so we're going to start from the bottom
up and kind of take that chart in
Reverse for a second
um one of the areas that we want to
highlight here was vertex gen AI studio
if you haven't seen this is an area in
which you can be able to get a simple UI
interface and experience in two models
uh what is really interesting here
is that as you can see this little GIF
that's planned if you can't see in the
back apologies for its small text we
have people who are actually
experimenting with an llm at the moment
and being able to give some inputs and
prompts and be able to start doing some
tuning of the parameters around which
they wanted to be able to respond on and
it's a very simple UI to start playing
experiment to understand what we have
the reason why this is really cool is
because this gets paired with vertex
model Garden which is a One-Stop shop to
be able to get your Google and open
source models that are ready to use tune
and such right out of the box
with this you can be able to use this
for foundation models directly you can
tune your foundation models customize
them and you have API access the test
specific Solutions so the whole point
here that we're showing is that there is
right at the very beginning an access to
the model layer to be able to start
building your application on top of
whichever application you have
more specifically though we actually
started building some demos where we
actually start showing the application
that we asked here for asses
um today we have here Vector search
which is formerly known as matching
engine if you've ever seen this before
and it is a highly scalable managed
Vector service the build your own search
recommendation and so on and so forth
imagine uh having a nearest neighbor
scalable engine and such
um what we're showing here is a
reference architecture because this
one's very bad built and you can see the
embedded index that's essentially going
to be Vector search here with some other
pieces that we add here such as palm and
some apis that we can be able to
interface with it and some areas from
your document database and such for what
we're about to show you the whole
purpose of this is because it's highly
highly scalable it's pretty easy
documentation interface with some more
updates coming over the next couple of
months for this and make it more
developer friendly and it has Enterprise
grade security and compliance it can be
used for a whole variety of use cases
not just for search and information
retrieval but information security
multimodal search recommendations so and
so forth so with that I'm going to pause
and hand it over to pulse who's going to
be able to show us a pretty awesome demo
of that's actually running yes hello
everybody so today we're going to take a
look at three different search and
information retrieval tools using a set
of documents for cloud developer
relations onboarding to the job that I
do well I have to be careful about that
so we want to be able to show you the
varying levels of control and
abstraction that you can use when
building your applications so we'll
start first with vertex AI Vector search
which gives you the ability to configure
everything end to end and this can work
pretty well whenever you have the
resources and expertise to create and
use your own embeddings or if you have
specific tools that you want to use for
various steps in the pipeline so I'm
going to show you a sample application
that was actually created by my
colleague Daniel Rodriguez that uses a
front end on Firebase document AI for
document optical character recognition
Palm 2 long large language model and
vertex AI Vector search
so if I can get into my machine
hopefully the Wi-Fi is going to
cooperate today we shall see so this is
a simple little application that builds
a question answer system specifically
for employee onboarding of developer
relations so one of the first things you
might want to know about this is say
what is devrel or developer relations so
it says developer relations is the
practice of building and maintaining
relationships with developers devrel
team's responsible for educating
developers better company's products and
services helping them to integrate those
products and services into their own
work we also work on building a
community developers around companies
products and services and to help
developers to solve problems and learn
from each other and this is all all the
actual matching is done using the
approximate nearest neighbor algorithm
with vertex AI Vector search and then
all of the user input and output are fed
through the Palm llm to give kind of a
natural language response of this so
let's try something else on this one of
the big things about developer relations
Is that we go to conferences so maybe I
should ask
what first party conferences if I can
spell
should I go to
and here we go so first party
conferences the ones hosted by Google
these include Google Cloud next which we
are at right now Google I O and Google
developers live which is part of Google
I O and Google and Google Cloud next
okay so let's move back over to talk a
little bit of vertex AI conversation
okay can we switch back to the slides
please thank you
I'll pause here for one second because
you just saw a whole lot from Holt but
mostly short this is an overview of the
reference architecture to Holt was just
showing that they created for their
application
so that was quite a bit of work
let's go up the stack a little bit
one of the other options you have here
is vertex conversation where you can
build a dynamic and personalized
conversational experience quickly
traditionally called these chat Bots
this is sort of I'm awesome chatbot in
this some pretty awesome benefits you
get from this multimodal chat voice
images so and so forth generative
responses combined with deterministic
business logic so you can imagine
everyone in a contact center or call
center to be able to fall back when you
have clear Rules of Engagement or
actions that you want being taken and
not just having the LM try to interpret
people take transactions and automate
actions with workflows and generators
and so the Bots could start taking
actions on your behalf you might have
seen some of the store in our demos
during the keynote yesterday
and then also low code bot Builder and
being able to set up your Bot your flows
and so on so forth there's quite a bit
more behind this but this is some pretty
awesome highlights that you get here and
so we're going to show a demo where we
took the same information underline
information for ask ipsos in this
context in terms of being a developer
relations and showing you how we
instantiated with this demo as well
okay
so here we're going to show an example
oh we need to flip over yeah we're good
so look at an example chat bot built
with vertex AI conversation and this
allows you to build a chatbot that can
answer questions based on specific
documents that you upload and then you
can manage all of it in dialogflow CX so
you can also access other latest
features of dialogflow CX like
generators and generative fallback okay
excellent
I'm in the dialogflow CX console you can
actually access the bus that you create
through the the vertex AI console and
then it opens it up in dialog flow here
this is using the exact same set of
documents that we use for that Vector
search demo here let's say I want to
look at some different kind of insert
information here something that's really
popular for developers is labs and
Hands-On guides that give you a nice
easy way to get started with a product
so let's see if I should ask it what
kinds of tools
can build labs for Developers
very nice so hopefully this is big
enough so everyone can see it I can try
and zoom in a little bit here we go
nice so in this case it gave me an
answer based on some documents that have
already been uploaded into this the
tools that can build labs for developers
include quick Labs codelabs GitHub
Jupiter notebooks Google Docs and Neo's
tutorials pretty cool here so what if I
well you know code Labs that's a term
that maybe not everyone is familiar with
so what if I asked it
um what
let's see or how do I make a code lab
all right
and here we go it actually gives me a
bunch of links for exactly how to the
home page for them how to author them
using Google Docs how to use them author
them using markdown the formatting guide
all that kind of information and so all
this takes just a few minutes to set up
all you have to do is basically give a
link to the documents that you're going
to use and then vertex AI conversation
will go through and read through all
those documents you give it or the
websites or the structured data and then
it builds the spot around it so that you
can basically just go in and ask
questions you know right away after it's
done indexing so let's take a look let's
go one further step up the stack and
talk a little bit about vertex AI search
foreign
is this working nice and then lastly we
have vertex search which was already
alluded to in the very beginning as the
choice of implementation or solution for
s ipsos in the context you get an out of
the box personalized search to answer
complex queries and grind on your data
some of the other really cool aspects
that you get with this generative
asomerization citations alone prompt
multi-turn and you're seeing an example
of this here where a user is able to put
in not only search terminology but be
able to file with following questions
and it retains context over the
multi-turns customizable at the ml
models and embeddings and in the
rankings itself grounded on unstructured
data websites and structured data and
then data connectors access controls and
Enterprise compliance so this sounds
really close to what JC was saying that
they really needed for their acid
sourcing people to get internal
information and so we can also show you
a demo of the same data again running
with this sort of instantiation
beautiful
okay can we go back to the demo screen
please
yeah so the last one that we're going to
look at here
is for vertex AI search and this is kind
of the highest level of the stack so
essentially it gives you you know not
quite as much controls not as many uh
buttons and whistles as you can do with
vertex a vector search but the idea is
that it's really easy to get set up and
started so you can ingest websites
structured data or unstructured data
into a search engine and within minutes
you have something that you can deploy
and use in your applications ready to go
so I'm going to literally just go
through the process here of how to
create the how to create one of these so
you can see how you know how quick and
easy it is to set this sort of stuff up
so I am currently in the generative AI
app builder section of the Google Cloud
console
and so I already have a few search
engines here set up but if I wanted to
create a new one I can just go here to
new app and I'm going to try and zoom in
a couple of clicks just so you can see
it better
so in this case I'm going to select the
type of app as search if you want to
create a chat app you could just do this
one or if you wanted to do something
with content recommendations you could
do that as well
okay we have a few different features
that are available here we have
Enterprise Edition features Advanced LM
features
so I'm going to call this one cloud
onboarding
then select a region in this case I'm
going to use a global region
and then I can go in here and create a
new data store and this is where I'm
actually going to upload my data for
this
and in this case I'm going to use some
data in cloud storage
in this case all I have to do is provide
a cloud storage link to the data I want
to ingest this is all unstructured
documents which includes PDFs HTML plain
text there's also preview options for
Microsoft Word docs and PowerPoint as
well
and if you were going to be using one of
the third-party connectors it's going to
be available for vertex AI search and
the rest of vertex AI you could also add
that in here at this time
so continue I'm going to give quick name
for this this will be
cloud onboarding documents
and then select this data store and
we're going to create our search engine
and then that's pretty much all that you
have to do for the actual configuration
part now it's going to take a little bit
of time to index these documents but you
know in True TV chef style I have one
that I made earlier to you know because
we don't want to sit here and watch this
thing index so once you actually have
this open here there's a little preview
window that you can actually go in and
test this out so what if I asked a
similar question to before such as what
is devrel and we can also see here how
the foundation models under the hood can
provide some different results depending
on which implementation you're using
here
in here
so what is devrel devrel's a team people
who work developers to help them
successfully adopt Technologies they do
this by creating outbound content such
as blog posts videos and code labs and
by delivering developer feedback
internally so when you do have a high
level of control like you do with a
Vertex say a vector search your results
might differ depending on which exact
models you choose to use or how the
actual matching happens under the hood
so something else really neat you can do
here with vertex AI search is that you
can ask follow-up questions and it uses
the context of the previous question to
dictate its next response so what else
do they do
here we go devrel also builds demos
writes code speaks a developer
conferences and meetups like I'm doing
right now and gives Deep dive
presentations to customers and gets
feedback from external developers so
there we go we have some nice answers
about this sort of stuff so now what if
I wanted to forget the context of
already done and I want to ask a brand
new question
you know who next can get very busy for
folks inside and outside of Google
anyone who's working with Cloud should
know that
um and so what if I want to ask how do I
maintain work life balance
here we go to maintain work-life balance
you should disconnect from Google after
a day at work don't monitor email turn
off notifications or simply log out of
your email program you should also block
up time on your calendar for focused
work no meetings time and communicate
your working hours with your
stakeholders sounds great so probably
taken a little bit of a little vacation
time on this
on this but you disconnect from all this
now something great here
it not only gives you this actual
response but it gives you all of the
search results specifically the
documents that were used to generate
that response in a sense this kind of
eliminates the issue of hallucinations
that you can see with large language
models because it only generates that
answer up there based on the documents
that you give it
so with that
let's see here I just wanted to go and
show you a couple of the other settings
you can make with it you can edit with
this so this right here is a pre-built
widget that you can easily copy and
paste into your application there's a
few settings you can enable in this you
can do search of follow-up search or
that answer enable or disable
autocomplete enable feedback for example
the end users can say this is a good
answer this is not a good answer
and the actual integration side of this
if it will load
nice
so we actually have this pre-built
widget here that you can copy and paste
directly into any HTML site and then it
works automatically out of the box and
it looks exactly like what you see
right here it'll give you just a nice
little box that you can click on and
it'll open up this in the full screen
view so that you can use this kind of
pre-built search engine right on your
page now if you want to do something
more customized then you can use the
client libraries which will show you the
link to that in just a second
and you can build your own UI on top of
it but this gives you a nice quick way
to get started and get something up and
running so excellent let's move back
into
the slides
so everything we're showing here you can
customize and instantiate in your own
application in any which way you'd like
there's apis available obviously you can
build on top of all this the US are here
to speed up understanding how to use the
tools and such but obviously this is
more entirely back-end services and
infrastructure that we're offering
through vertex so what we're going to go
through real quick is a couple really
cool highlights that kind of help the
linear differentiate between the
different solutions and ways that you
approach that we put in here but all
this is coming with vertex and is
interoperable with the different
services that we just showed you
so the purpose of what we're trying to
do here just to ground everyone no pun
intended is that we're building stuff
out of the box for any Loco developers
building software application developers
where you can customize and building
stuff very deeply for the mlai
practitioners and building your own
models building your own tuning
embeddings so and so forth
well we're additional here was the
search and conversation that we
announced the ga
this looks really complicated the show
the purpose of this is to make it really
simple that we've already built many of
the flows the infrastructure the back
end that's required to be able to do
this well scalable controllable inside
where you can be able to put in a whole
bunch of different input information be
able to orchestrate across with our
connectors grounded in extensions which
we'll get into in a few minutes to be
able to get your outputs for your users
and consumers
one of the things that we just touched
on here was Data connectors announced
here at the conference data connectors
in this case we've already had cloud
storage bigquery and we've launched in
public websites and being able to go
Carl and query and public websites we're
also announcing 3p services today with
Salesforce jira and confluence
we're adding more to this actually quite
rigorously over the next six months as
well and this is going to be open to
being able to build 3p services so it's
not just stuff coming directly from
Google we have partners that are
building for this and we have it open in
a way that you can also build your own
connectors for any bespoke internal
systems that you already have and have
created
grounding is incredibly important people
probably see in about llms and
hallucination and one of the things that
we're doing with search as an example
but not the only example is we're
granted on all of your local data what's
really cool is the way that we're able
to also combine this with web data with
llm knowledge so and so forth so here's
a really simple example if you're not
familiar with grounding you can have an
input prompt here that's saying explain
what 401K benefits and contribution
limit
and the model output is going to say for
2023 you can contribute 2 000 22 500 to
an individual company will match 50
percent
up to eight percent of your contribution
which sounds very generous
the way that I didn't write this by the
way
the way the reason why this is important
because we highlighted here is that some
of this is coming clear from internal
company information in the yellow here
and in the yellow we're actually showing
over here that vertex search is actually
going in and looking through your
documents within the company that's been
given access to and provided secure uh
you know understanding of and it says
hey I already understand how much my
company will match on that but I don't
understand the Federal Regulation and
the changes that happened for 2023. so
in this case they're also combining this
with a public search that they put
together and having all this data as
part of the Enterprise search experience
and then one of the other parts that we
also were mentioning and here is
extensions
um and this is one of the reasons why we
want to bring this up because the
difference between connectors and
extensions think of connectors is
reading data bringing data in syncing
data extensions are more like taking
actions uh working with 3p systems and
so on and so forth
um examples here is we have stuff that's
being built by Partners doing it
backwards we have the stuff that's
integrated with Google and we showed a
lot of this in yesterday's keynote and
we're also leaving it open so you can
build your own again for custom internal
systems have been created for the
Enterprise or for things that just have
not been supported yet but is of high
priority for yourself
in doing this you'll be able to say that
it had prevents uh for data loss
prevention compliance on ability and
explainability because this is all being
done in a holistic systematic way and
there'll be more information coming on
this over the next six months as well
this is not just for the searching
conversation just to be clear this is
for everything that's being happening in
vertex and be able to extend models
themselves and so and so forth
and then the last thing here because
this comes up a lot this also looks
really complicated well I'll talk about
model customization a lot of people ask
about tuning trying to create their own
llms so and so forth there's a whole
range in here that you can be able to
actually do this
um some of this for people who've been
in mlai for quite a while now totally
understand the overhead and the
complications and the costs of trying to
train models and so what we have is
Right prompt design which essentially
saying just use the models right out of
the box start managing your prompts and
your inputs to be able to get the best
results that you that you're looking for
and this is actually highly effective
for many different purposes including
what we were just talking about before
multi-turn where we're keeping contacts
from the previous input so and so forth
in this we have adapter tuning which is
simply saying that we can create an
adapter model the purpose for this is
that you can keep your data private you
can keep your data totally without us
ever seen it in our instances in our
political clients and that data can
separate from the overall model
uh reinforcement learning human feedback
is a new thing that we announced with
Vector vertex Ai and that is an area
that you can update your weights models
reward as you can see this starts
getting more green which basically says
you're you're now changing the entire
model it's starting to tune the whole
thing and then you can do a full fine
tuning if if permits or is needed for
your use case we support all of this
including compliance and security and
such we're not covered in the session
but things like dedicated instances and
so on and so forth are also being made
available depending on security
requirements and latency and such
so the purpose of today's conversation
was that we took one use case in general
there were actually many use cases that
we're seeing a lot of Great Value that's
being added in the tools that we're
burning this is just a small subset of
those uh to be clear but we want to
highlight that what we just showed today
could be reused to build any of these
types of use cases using your data being
able to be specific for your Enterprise
requirements and it's not just from
compliance but also from the use case
and I should be able to meet the
requirements to fulfill the End customer
needs
so last one this looks really
complicated but in short we went from
the small chart that kind of gave me a
really brief overview
to a little bit more of an extent I'm
going to walk through what we just kind
of did of some of the solutions at the
top here we have in here our search and
chat and we talked about how we're
orchestrating across all those already
for you as the customers and the
developers we're giving you a lot of
control in addition to the data
connectors grounded in extensions to be
able to customize and tune for your
needs and then we have our core platform
areas here where we have our model
garden with our first party open source
and partner models as well as all the
traditional mlai notebooks and training
jobs and so on and so forth there
so with all that said Holt wanted to
speak to his demos yes of course so is
everybody excited to get started using
some of this stuff
here we go
so if you want to get started here I
would highly recommend going to this
lovely QR code here I promise it's not
going to spam me anything so this will
go directly to this guide in the
documentation uh you know we have uh get
started with Enterprise search the old
name for for a text AI search because
we're moving fast we're getting
everything so this takes you to a lovely
video that it looks like there's some
guy here that you know might want to
tell you a little more about this and
also one of my colleagues Kaz Sato
is an expert in bettings and all that
kind of stuff so he talks about the uh
what's actually going on under the hood
with semantic and keyword searching but
so this gives you nice step-by-step
guide to go exactly how to create a
search engine for all the different
types of data it also gives you a nice
walk through in the cloud console
directly and so this if you just go
there it'll take you to this guy there's
also guides for how to create a
generative chat app generative AI agents
which is the protects that conversation
stuff we talked about so you can easily
find all of this going on in there
for more resources here my team in Cloud
developer advocacy has a full video
series called generative AI for
developers and this gives you a nice
conceptual overview of pretty much
everything generative AI on Google cloud
and this QR code just goes directly to
that playlist
okay everyone got the everything taken
pictures of
okay I'll give you like two more seconds
here to do that
okay you can also Google search this to
find what you're looking for
and
for all of the all of you who want to
have some sample applications to try and
hack around with we have a GitHub
repository now the phones are really
coming out everybody's really interested
with this this is a GitHub repository
maintained by my team that has a bunch
of different sample applications Jupiter
notebooks uh sample code demos and stuff
for all the generative AI features of
vertex AI so we have a sample web app
using
um using vertex AI search we have some
stuff for chat we have some notebooks
using the Palm models Tech spice and
chat bison Gekko we have some stuff for
vision and image generation we have
stuff for speech everything it's your
kind of One Stop Shop for any sort of
sample code relating to generative AI on
Google Cloud
foreign